we've got a story straight from the
heart this morning it came to us from
our Houston affiliate KHOU a boy with
autism whose name is Carson blew a
bubble one day and gum popped all over
his face bully swarmed his wrist was
broken and so was his heart he suffered
the kind of bullying that millions of
other kids endure some daily but the
world can be an incredibly generous
place I put out a call on social media
looking for video game designers who
jumped in quickly to help us make Carson
feel special
he loves me
we're best friends so this started as a
story about what's wrong with the world
what's broken so I was walking home from
the bus stop and a kid made me fall and
I broke this because it hurt your
feelings that he did that yeah yeah it
sort of does Carson Thompson a 13 year
old boy with autism left with his arm in
a sling so I called Carson's mom and
asked her what is the one thing that
would just set his soul on fire and she
said well if he could meet a video game
designer that's what he hopes to be one
day
in fact when he's not playing games he's
pacing through the backyard planning for
the games he'll create
I didn't tell him anything what does he
know so far he knows nothing
on this day he was in for a big surprise
video games are the highest form of art
you got art music in the future I want
to make games like um
I have a lot of ideas he had no idea
that he was on his way to meet a team of
designers who do just that hey Carson
welcome to six foot studios you know
what we do here
games
place is awesome this is just a Lobby
[Music]
there you go
that we had before so I can see I just
myself
don't worry about any of those things
okay thank you so much
how is today for you today was awesome
I'm pretty inspired I think that I am
going to make the best game ever created
oh I like that I like that I love that
best video game yet and you know video
games are a real high form of art you
can see him pacing thing through the
story the combination of creativity the
engineering it's narrative yeah he's
going to do something great you know
what's interesting when we air stories
like this on broadcasts we usually don't
know what impact they'll have but this
thing we did a little differently we
posted Carson's story on social media
first and I got to tell y'all the
reaction was priceless uh let me share a
little bit of it Carrie Kaylee actually
wrote my son Carson is 11. same name
Carson he has ADHD and autism and this
touched mom mama heart the world needs
more kindness like this Katie commented
I love this so much this precious boy
these beautiful guys I feel like my
Grinchy heart
and there was a lot of support for
Carson in his future Joshua wrote the
sky's the limit Carson can't wait for
the best game ever I'll purchase it but
the best part is what it did for Carson
that's what I like out of all this yes
to go through something he comes out on
the other side yeah and I got to tell
you this came to us from our cameraman
Dwayne who lives in Houston he saw it
and he sent it to me and I called
Carson's mom how's he doing and she's
good she said good and I said has there
been an outpouring of support she said
well people want to give him material
things but because of his autism
material things don't really matter to
him I said well what would just throw
him over the edge and she said to meet a
video game designer and I put out a call
on social media and instantly they
started popping up in six foot studios
in Houston thanks guys within 48 hours
open the doors wow that's the positive
side of social media right yes yes that
was awesome we need more of that David
positive side coming up coming up all
right we got more David bigner tomorrow
you'll be in for what to watch right
right all right